dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr carol jonai fajir
today's paper is about creating
synthetic human faces
and not only that but it can also make
me look
like obi-wan kenobi you will see the
rest of this footage in a few minutes
now of course this is not the first
paper to generate
artificial human faces for instance in
december 2019
a technique by the name stargen2 was
published
this is a neural network-based learning
algorithm that is capable of
synthesizing these eye-poppingly
detailed images
of human beings that don't even exist
this work answered some questions and as
any good paper
raised many more good ones for instance
generating images of virtual humans is
fine but
what if the results are not exactly what
we are looking for
can we have some artistic control over
the outputs
how do we even tell the ai what we are
looking for
well we are in luck because target 2
offers
somewhat rudimentary control over the
outputs where we can give it
input images of two people and fuse them
together
now that is absolutely amazing but i
wonder if we can
ask for a little more can we get even
more granular control
over these images what if we could just
type in
what we are looking for and somehow the
ai would understand
and execute our wishes is that possible
or is that science fiction
well hold on to your papers and let's
see
this new technique works as follows we
type what aspect of the input image we
wish to change
and what the change should be
wow really cool and we can
even play with these sliders to adjust
the magnitude of the changes
as well this means that we can give
someone a new hairstyle
add or remove makeup
or give them some wrinkles for good
measure
now the original stargen2 method worked
on not only humans
but on a multitude of different classes
too
and the new technique also inherits this
property
look we can even design new car shapes
make them a little sportier or make our
adorable cat
even cuter for some definition of cuder
of course
we can even make their hair longer
or change their colors and the results
are of super high quality
absolutely stunning while we are
enjoying some more results here
make sure to have a look at the paper in
the video description
and if you do you will find that we
really just crashed the surface here
for instance it can even add clouds to
the background of an image
or redesign the architecture of
buildings
and much much more there are also
comparisons against previous methods in
there
showcasing the improvements of the new
method
and now let's experiment a little on me
look this is me here after i got locked
up for dropping my papers
and i spent so long in there that i grew
a beard
or i mean a previous learning based ai
called
style flow gave me one and since
dropping your papers is a serious crime
the sentence is long quite long
ouch i hereby promise to never drop my
papers
ever again so now let's try to move
forward with this image
and give it to this new algorithm for
some additional work
this is the original and by original
i mean the image with the added
algorithmic beard
from a previous ai and this is the
embedded version
of the image this image looks a little
different
why is that it is because target 2
runs an embedding operation on the photo
before starting its work
this is its own internal understanding
of my image if you will
this is great information and is
something that we can only experience
if we have hands-on experience with the
algorithm
and now let's use this new technique to
apply some more magic to this image
this is where the goodness happens and
oh my it does not disappoint
you see it can gradually transform me
into obi-wan kenobi
an elegant algorithm for a more
civilized age
but that's not all it can also create a
ginger karoy
hippi karoy karoy who found
a shiny new paper on fluid simulations
and karoy who read
set paper outside for quite a while and
was perhaps
disappointed and now hold on to your
papers and please welcome
dr carolina jonaifer
and one more i apologize in advance
rockstar carroy with a mohawk
how cool is that i would like to send a
huge thank you
to the authors for taking their time out
of their work day
to create these images only for us you
can really
only see this here on two minute papers
and as you see
the pace of progress in machine learning
research is absolutely
stunning and with this the limit of our
artistic workflow is not going to be our
mechanical skills
but only our imagination what a time to
be alive
this video has been supported by weights
and biases
check out the recent offering fully
connected
a place where they bring machine
learning practitioners together
to share and discuss their ideas learn
from industry leaders
and even collaborate on projects
together
you see i get messages from you fellow
scholars telling me
that you have been inspired by the
series but
don't really know where to start and
here it is
fully connected is a great way to learn
about the fundamentals
how to reproduce experiments get your
papers
accepted to a conference and more make
sure to visit them through wnb dot
me papers or just click the link in the
video description
our thanks to weights and biases for
their long-standing support
and for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support and i'll see you
next time